[Music]
this is the ramsey show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host this is
common sense for your dollars and cents
yeah we teach you to live on less than
you make a concept congress can't grasp
it's a free call at triple eight eight
two five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
the call is free and some say the advice
is worth exactly what you pay for it
landon is in memphis hey landon welcome
to the ramsay show
hey dave i appreciate you taking my call
my pleasure sir what's up
so i have a question regarding real
estate um i'm 25 my wife is 23. um we
have our house is paid for and we don't
have any debt wow so
uh i really i love real estate so our
goal is to save up and pay cash for
rental real estate but i'm also very
interested to get my license and selling
also
but
i just don't know if it's worth my time
you know like i just don't know a lot of
people that necessarily want to buy or
sell their biggest asset from a to a 25
year old
um and so you know that's the only thing
that worries me because i also have
another business but it's not very
demanding i can run it pretty easily but
i don't know it
it isn't something that i should even
consider so i just worry about saying
that i'm paying cash for rental real
estate
oh you should consider you should do it
but because you're wise enough to
realize that you've got a barrier that
you've got to come over i got my license
when i turned 18 and sold my first house
three weeks later but that you know who
buys a house from an 18 year old the
other guy wasn't there very smart but
right
but um yeah i mean i did it and i i sold
real estate all the way through college
and um you know all the way up into my
20s and so um
yeah you should do it but you're right i
mean uh
a little gray in the temples is helpful
um
i mean i'm not afraid of the i'm not
afraid of the berry or anything i mean i
know it's there i'm not i'm definitely
not afraid of work
but you just have to you just have to
put it out there you have to be so
stinking professional and good
that it never occurs to them how young
you are
right have you ever like i've got i've
got a young guy on my team here that's
30.
but i swear to god his soul is 40
or 50.
not that he's like an old man i don't
mean that but he's just an old soul he's
wise beyond his years he carries himself
with a poise and a confidence and he he
uh
you know he's a leader on our team and
he
people follow him as if he's two decades
older than he is because the way he
carries himself and because of his
expertise and because of the
you know his intellect and so on and so
you know you just have to put other
stuff out there for them to focus on the
good stuff rather than going this is a
kid you know because because for 60 year
olds 25 year olds a kid right so but uh
right you know and you may run into some
of that but you run into it you know my
mama got her license in 1966 before
women were in the real estate business
and uh you know we got hate mail in the
mailbox because how dare a woman sell
real estate and worse than that she
didn't wear a dress she wore a pantsuit
oh my god
she must have been a feminist but
anything but i'll just tell you that but
anyway but the uh but you know i mean it
was an obstacle to overcome she ended up
selling more houses than my dad did and
he was in the business too so
um right you know she was a great
salesperson and uh
and now ladies run that whole world but
uh
but so you know you overcome it and
here's the beautiful thing the real
estate business is more and more and
more app driven digital driven web
driven internet driven today
than it than even it was 18 months ago
and so you'll be your your age will give
you an advantage over my age
in that because it's second nature to
you
right okay i see something yes you
should go do it
okay
because you're wise enough to recognize
it might be a barrier and the way you
overcome it is with just unbelievable
personal excellence
and uh be that old soul
and then uh
that that uh
74 year old widow lady will go
oh you know little land and he just took
such good care of me
and you know that's exactly what she'll
be saying right and she'll send all of
her friends to you and that's what'll
happen done and that's the way it works
judith is with us in chicago hi judith
how are you
hi good thank you so much for taking my
call i really appreciate it my pleasure
what's up so
my husband and i are in a little
different
of opinion about um oh you're sorry
no no we're friendly friendly a friendly
fight it's a marriage fight it's a fun
yes people ask me why are we fighting
so
um if i can give you a little just a
little background of our finances
um currently we have 41 000 in student
loans
um we have a house that we still owe
like 492
000 on
um
and we we are currently paying
for two cars monthly
that come out to almost like 800
a month gee what do you own these cars
what do we owe yeah what do you owe on
each car how much money do you owe on
each car
um so we owe for my minivan 22
and for my husband's car it's 6 000.
what's your household income
it's 300 000. okay
all right and 41 022 and six is that the
total of your debt not counting your
house
correct
okay exactly so how quick are you gonna
pay off sixty thousand bucks making
three hundred
so my husband um says that we can put
three thousand a month
towards
the um towards debt and that would take
approximately
does that make sense two years yeah
that's fairly wimpy
um yeah thirty six thousand out of three
hundred oh you're sacrificing
not
you with me true okay seventy thousand
out of thirty three hundred thousand and
you are done in one yeah
so what are we fighting about again
so we have four kids one with special
needs
um so
we kind of feel like we need i don't
know if we need or it's very helpful to
have two cars because i'm constantly
taking the kid
around to appointments and stuff and my
husband needs to get to work so do we
sell
one of these cars no do we
no
no just hold on
you should keep the car you should sit
down and do a written budget and when
you get through kicking your own butt
for how much money you're wasting out of
300k
you'll see that you can pay off
everything on this list except your
house in one year
70 from 300k is 230 000 left over minus
taxes call the ambulance i think you
guys can make it
that's the conversation
i'm being mean but i'm trying to point
out to you that if you if you have that
conversation with yourselves
and you go oh my gosh we're playing
around with this we need to get serious
and stay out of restaurants and quit
going on trips and pay off the stinking
minivan i got a special needs kid and no
we're not selling my car i don't know
who it was want to sell the car but they
just lost this argument
well then i i lost it okay
all right i thought we should sell the
car that's awful you got your i kicked
your butt and didn't let you win oh my
god i'm so sorry
what about selling it for a cheaper car
no no no your car's not your problem
your unwillingness to sacrifice the rest
of your lifestyle is your problem your
car's not out of line out of a 300 000
budget you're doing just fine you're
gonna get it girl you got it you got
this you need to keep that car you got
those kiddos they're counting on that
car and you that van special needs you
got stuff you need to do there it's not
out of line
if you call me up and you owe a hundred
thousand dollars on your cars and you
make a hundred thousand i'm selling
everything in sight and making fun of
you too but not that's not you darling
you guys are in good shape you can do
this
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at betheltech.net
and get one thousand to twenty five
hundred dollars off of your tuition
again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
you guys believe christmas is 12 days
away
that happened fast
it sneaks up on us like they move it or
something we've got the ramsey christmas
cash giveaway going on we've been giving
away 500 a week and this is your last
week to enter for your chance to win the
500 or the 5 000
grand prize no purchase is necessary
ramsay solutions dot com slash giveaway
and for an extra dose of motivation in
time for the new year we're having our
famous ten dollar sale you can shop from
over 40 of our best-selling books and
envelope systems for just ten dollars
each number one best seller the total
money makeover rachel cruz's newest
number one know yourself know your money
new york times best seller all 10 bucks
10 bucks 10 bucks 10 bucks 10 bucks
check them out they're all there for
sale you do not want to
miss out on this all kinds of good
things there's a few of the christy
wright
2022
planners available they make great gifts
for the ladies especially
uh it's a little bit of a
inspiration information calendar
everything all tied gold planner
everything all set in together you do
not want to miss out on these just a
handful of them left we always buy to
where we sell out because you know it
you know
pretty soon the 2022 calendar is
worthless so you know that doesn't have
a long shelf life so there you go it's
going to be gone and you're going to
miss if you don't get those all at
ramseysolutions.com
our question today comes from blinds.com
find out for yourself why blinds.com is
the number one online retailer of custom
window coverings free samples free
shipping new promos all the time always
use the magic word the promo code ramsey
nicole's in michigan i started a home
bakery earlier this year i'm wanting to
move my bakery to a restaurant space
serving breakfast and lunch as well as
our baked good offerings i'll be dumping
all my savings into this restaurant and
going all in
am i making a wise decision to use all
my savings on this dream
well nicole um
you don't want your dream to become a
nightmare
failure
is a part of business
if you're in business you're going to
have failure the trick is to have
non-fatal failure
don't have a failure that takes you out
and that the way you solve that trick is
the size of the failure
so have lots and lots and lots of little
ouchies instead of one where you lose
your head
don't get taken out all my savings means
i have no money
that's not good nicole
because here's the three rules of
business
rule number one a business it takes
twice as long as you think it's going to
rule number two it costs twice as much
as you think it's going to
rule number three you're not the
exception
so when you move into this little
restaurant and you've got it all figured
out and you have exactly enough just to
open the doors
you're going to run out of money and go
broke
because it's going to take longer than
you thought it was going to because your
projections are based on a wet finger in
the air you don't know what this thing's
going to produce the only thing you know
is what you've been producing
with your home bakery
earlier this year
so my suggestion would be
and you're not going to like it because
everybody wants to go fast and not slow
but my suggestion would be run that home
bakery a little bit longer pile up a
little more money
a lot more money
get your recipes and your customer base
dialed in
know more about the business than you
know nine months after you opened it
it's still a little baby business
it just started it's cute
but we don't want to pledge our whole
thing on the back of this baby business
i've done stupid stuff like this kid
that's how i know i got a phd in dumb
i have done so much stuff that has cost
me money
and lost money
and i have become an expert in the last
five years about making smaller mistakes
because most of my mistakes have been
colossal yes some of my failures have
been or some of my successes have been
colossally large as well
but um
i'm convinced that we are where we are
based on about 10 percent of our best
ideas the other 90 sucked
and when you're in the shower on the
running trail all your ideas sound smart
in your head
so please go slower please don't move in
with no money and hope you're gonna be
okay lack of liquidity lack of retained
earnings to survive a downturn
your little uh town that you're in could
have a little coveted hiccup and
somebody decided to go all communists
and shut the whole place down and then
you'd be out of business and your
savings is all gone
and so there you go
and you've got to have a little more
wiggle room than you got right now and
your business is not big enough
dial it up dial it up dial it up and
then launch it so if i were you if you
were my daughter and i was sitting down
with you i would say live your dream
baby but don't make it a nightmare
i want you to own a bakery for the rest
of your life and be successful and be
highly popular and written up in
magazines as the finest baker in the
world and everybody's got to go to
nicole's place over on 4th avenue or
wherever it is i want that to be you
and your best route to get there is wait
one more year at least
get your customer base up
begin to tease them about what's coming
coming next year
coming in 23 coming attractions
on the next episode of nicole's bakery
that's what you tease them build build
your base build your tribe
uh and build your money and you'll have
a much better
experience with your life jane is with
us in atlanta hi jane how are you
hey dave i'm doing good how are you
doing better than i deserve what's up
well um
i was hoping i need a neutral party here
my sister and i um
have have inherited mom's home uh she
died in april 2016.
we inherited decided to rent it out um
after painting it getting all ready in
october of 2017.
um we also have inherited a cabin in the
north georgia mountains so we share both
of these properties
um since we've been renting in october
17th neither one of us has taken a draw
at all it's been going into a shared
account which we use to pay the taxes
insurance repairs
maintain the cabin and the home for both
of those
so um this lawn service everything uh
so since we have not taken a draw yet um
i asked her the other day i said what do
you think about taking draw oh no no no
we want to um she wants to continue to
rent it i want to sell it since we i
don't feel like we're making any money
off of it um it just seems like the
money pit it was built in 1957.
what's it worth and um
you know and the the cabin was built in
the 80s i think we hang on to the cabin
what's the house worth
um we i asked her to get an appraised
but she's having a real she's going to
talk to a real estate agent it's in the
tampa bay area and she's um talking to a
real roughly agent
roughly what's it worth oh maybe maybe
350 400 000 okay pretty substantial
would be like that okay
um so here's the thing neither one of
you lived there
he lives right next door to it see i'm
saying
we're all retirement age or coming up on
retirement age i'm 58 she's 55.
um her and her husband are retiring next
year
and she wants to i think she wants to
hang on to it for a compound
property kind of thing and then sell
everything but my timetable's not her
timetable
maybe she should just buy you out
i don't think they can afford to do that
um and i don't want to i just i i hate i
don't want to cause any
rift in the family i'm not trying to
cause a rift in the family
because you want to sell it and she
doesn't she's causing the rift
thank you
well i mean that that's not cause that's
not causing the conflict the conflict is
you have two different goals with the
same property uh would would you one of
you would you consider taking the cabin
and letting her have that
she would never do that because they're
in florida they love to get away from
the north okay so she likes the cabin
too
she likes the cabin too
so here here's what i would propose i i
say you know if you get that get down
there in person and have a cup of coffee
with her and her husband just say listen
i love you all more and i love this
house but i really don't want to own
this house anymore
so
let's have it appraised and i will sell
you my half at a deep discount just to
help you get into it because i want out
of it
and and so let's say it appraises for
400.
if you sold it you're gonna net 85 of
that max
so sell it seller your half for you know
75 or 70
you don't need the money it's not about
the money it's about this thing's not
making any money
and so you're still going to put a 100
000 and some change in your pocket go
off and do an investment somewhere and
she's going to own the house
that's what i would do
let me just have a personal in-person
conversation gently pined i don't want
to cause a rift but i don't want to own
the house anymore so we'll give you a
big discount let's work this out
[Music]
left
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry it's
worth it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage that can only mean one
thing chris and stacy are with us hi
guys how are you hi dave thank you where
do you guys live
rogers minnesota what's that near
minneapolis oh okay cool fun welcome to
nashville good to have you guys and your
debt debt-free how much did you pay off
355 659 dollars and 12 cents
okay do it again your wife was turning
around on the back of the t-shirt and
i'm squinting i can't see the little
friend from here 355. okay 355 000. how
long did this take 57 months five seven
months okay and uh what was your range
of income during that time 150 to 222.
cool what do you guys do for a living
i'm a high school teacher i'm an er
nurse awesome very cool
okay so 222 and in 57 months you paid
off 350 is that your house no we wished
everything but the house big student
loans yes okay all kids are out all the
kids oh paid for the kiddos okay cool
well you got them off the payroll yep on
to the next center on the next thing
excellent excellent so the 355 consisted
of what
uh the student loans the parent plus
loans uh we had a lot of other stupid we
had furniture we had cars we even took
out a loan on a car that was paid for to
get another loan on it
um
yeah very normal you were normal okay so
uh
what five years ago
yeah the thing the thing turns upside
down your whole life changes you go in a
different direction tell us your story
so dave we um took out a loan for 25 000
um we were starting to see the um
student loan payments come in and we
were getting kind of worried and um i
was looking at the dollar amount and i
said we got to go get a loan to kind of
consolidate some of our debt together
and the lady handed me a piece of paper
and said that we need to sign this and
she could pull out credit um for the
next six months if we took out any other
loans she would call our loan due
and i knew we needed to get serious
that's when it got real
so you came home and did what from that
that scared you that was your come to
jesus moment right it was yeah
i loved reading books about money and
but none of them could give us a really
plan that we needed
um
and interestingly enough for about two
years i had been teaching your program
in high school oh wow yeah he just
didn't share it i didn't share it with
her it was so simple i i felt like i'd
be an idiot when i brought it up because
she's reading stacks of
books all kinds of intelligent things
and
and you were teaching my stuff always
teaching yourself well it is so simple
it is so straight forward and simple
and so i i finally did i said
you might like this
i read it next week we made a plan wow
yeah just like that just like that it
was gaming that was perfect timing yeah
sure you know you had that moment where
that that uh stomach goes up in the
throat moment no nothing's ever the same
after that if you do something about it
right and you did something about it
congratulations
thank you sir well done i mean you've
been busting it for a long time
57 months is no that's not five months
that's 57 months
wow how did you stick with it for 57
months your podcast ah stay engaged and
back yep it was constant in our house
um
i'm the saying that people your swear
word in the house
you definitely were amongst several
people
okay so the teenagers didn't like that
um they were kind of out of the house it
was more of my family got really sick
and tired of listening to oh they just
had to hear you talk about it
okay all right to the point you print
t-shirts 50 and free for your for those
of you looking deeply into your radio
yeah they got t-shirts on 50 and free
that's good it's good to be free yes it
is wonderful i turned 50 in june and he
turns 51 in july but our last payment
was in june so we were both
yeah love it way to go how does it feel
to be free
amazing we've been married for 31 years
never thought we'd see this never been
debt-free at all 31 years ago
25 years is stupid yeah we probably
didn't think it was possible
no no it felt stuck
very much and that's why when that lady
holds that axe over your head at the
bank aren't they pleasant yes
she was very nice about it but i know
but if you if you take out one more
though and i'm just going to call you
alone and well thank you you're a big
help
oh my gosh yeah well she was a big help
did you end up taking that loan out and
it was part of this they did we ended up
taking it out and it was a big payment
and then got rid of her as soon as you
could yeah oh my gosh
wow that's so wild good for you guys
thank you okay now that you've done it
and now that you teach it in high school
and now that you actually know that it
works
um
and even though it's simple um
uh what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is
the budget the every dollar tool is
amazing we didn't even i mean we had the
money during the debt free time that we
were in it but we didn't even take out
the extra plus to spend the extra ten
dollars but i think it helped us
micromanage it every day too to not have
those little bubbles i had to move it i
had to do it myself yeah yeah being on
the same page is key
you got to be on the same page
and so now when you're with your high
school students you can say some of the
most profound
things you'll ever learn in your life
are simple i'm hoping this will really
help my credit in the classroom
or heard it you know we never know
depends on which cl high school student
we're talking about if i was in high
school i would make fun of dave ramsey
if i was in the class i would trash him
oh that's funny because i was that kid
but yeah our kids follow him now huh
follow you
okay cool
that's good good for you guys i'm so
proud of you very very very well done
oh man good stuff what are you gonna do
now that you're free anything we want
yeah
i'm gonna live breathe a little bit yeah
i feel like in the past with all the
debt you're never living in the moment
because you're so scared of what's going
to happen next and is that what the
tears were when you're talking about the
banker lady that was fear you remembered
the fear oh yeah
it is terrifying when other people have
control of your life
and this gives you your life back i'm so
proud of y'all you're cool people thank
you
you're neat well i'm honored that you
came down here to do your debt-free
screen merry christmas to you merry
christmas to you we got a copy of the uh
new book baby steps millionaires which
will be out in january i'm going to give
you an early copy i know a guy thank you
and uh we've got the advanced reader
copies that we send out to the press and
all
and um that's where you're going you're
gonna be there before you know it and uh
you'll be baby steps millionaires and
just have to have a whole new t-shirt
then yes yeah but uh it's good stuff
you'll probably be there by the time
you're 60 or sooner it's going to be
sooner yeah all right
good i'm glad to hear that and a copy
total money makeover for you to give to
someone put in their stack of books
maybe they'll even read it you never
know so we give it at every wedding that
we go to oh thank you very nice i
appreciate that the ten dollar sale
helps yeah it does people buy them by
the case for that purpose yeah
well thanks for hanging out with us
thanks for having us for having us chris
and stacy minneapolis minnesota 355
000 paid off in 57 months the first time
they're debt-free in 31 years of
marriage making 150 to 222. they had it
and they did it and they did what it
took count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
three two one we're dead free
[Applause]
that is how it's
done and you know there's people out
there that will tell you you can't do
this
that you're always going to be in debt
there are always going to be people to
tell you that your your loser uncle
your friend who's a loser
you're always going to be in debt you
can't get out what kind of a dream is
that you can't do that oh you're well
some debt's just part of life you need
to grow up and accept that sophisticated
people use debt no they don't
and yes you can
get out of debt
the only reason to get out of that is so
that
you can give
with outrageous generosity because when
you have any payments you can help other
people
broke people can't help other people
have you noticed that because they kind
of concerned about being broke
themselves
when you get out of debt you can build
wealth i mean you know how fast you be a
millionaire you start investing a house
payment
ding ding baby you'll be there in about
13 seconds it goes so fast y'all
we're just here for a vapor that's what
the bible says we're just here for a
short moment
and it goes really really fast so you
might as well do something with that
dash between the date on your tombstone
the date you came the date you leave
what are you gonna do with the dash well
let's make a decision it's a good time
of year to reset
really a good time to do that so let's
get with it man those guys right there
they're rock stars
they took a simple primitive idea
and changed their lives way to go chris
and stacy this is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
merry christmas america we're so glad
you're with us ho ho ho i love it i love
this season
because i got to tell you the most fun
you'll ever have with money is
generosity
if you've had a generosity experience
where you received something wonderful
and it was life-changing or maybe you
gave something and you were able to
participate
and be the conduit through which god
blessed someone
i want to hear your story
our last live broadcast of the year we
run tape the rest of the year is uh will
be december 22nd
and it'll be a live show three hours of
giving
we want your giving stories big time
giving stories where something big and
dramatic happen now if you if you once
left an extra dollar on the tip i don't
need that story okay uh we want to we
want to inspire other people with
outrageous
generosity receiving or giving i don't
care which side you're on and if you're
too humble because you were the actual
giver well you weren't the giver god was
the giver he just used you to do it shut
up we need your story because it
inspires other people to do the same
thing here's the thing
if we
increased our generosity in this culture
by just a few percentage points we could
make the government irrelevant
let me correct that they're actually
already irrelevant
we could make them admit that they're
irrelevant
they think they're fixing everything
and if we the people would take care of
we the people
it would put them out of business and
that'd just be a wonderful thing it'd be
a wonderful byproduct plus you know what
happens if that many people get
incredibly generous their lives change
everyone who's generous life's change
so go to ramseysolutions.com
ask
and put giving in the subject line we
want to hear your story kelly i'll get
back to you and schedule you to be on
the air we're not going to tell you what
to say but we're scheduling the calls
because we want to make sure we have
three full hours of giving stories
ramsey solutions dot com slash ask put
giving
in the subject line brandon is with us
in new york city hi brandon merry
christmas hi dave how are you better
than i deserve what's up
uh so i have a question for you my wife
and i are uh are in a bluff situation
and we have no debt to accept their
mortgage good uh we have about
yeah we have about two hundred thousand
on our mortgage remain the pay
and we're in a situation now where i
think we can uh get rid of all our debt
and we're just struggling on
which part of our assets uh that we
should take the money out of to
to pay it off so can i give you my uh is
our financial background real quick sure
what are the buckets
what are the buckets we can pull so we
have a rental property that's all paid
off
and it has uh we could get at least 200
000 for it
and your balance on your mortgage is
200.
correct yep okay all right
and that and that rental property brings
in about 800 a month gotcha
yep we have 120 000 in cash
and we have 220 000
uh in stocks and mutual funds
so
so that's it what's your household
income uh
uh 200 000. okay so what does a six
month or a three-month emergency fund
look like of expenses
probably 50 grand
yeah
let's round it up and call it let's call
it 70 grand let's call it 70 grand okay
then that means you have 50 000 too much
in cash laying around
yep okay unless you have something else
that that's earmarked for is it just
laying there
uh no that's just like that's just uh
well actually thirty thousand we have we
do have earmarked um
uh because we're going through an
adoption process so that is earmarked
okay so we got 20 000 left over then out
of that cash so we're going to set 30
over in the adoption fund we're going to
set 70 in the emergency fund and um and
we're going to throw 20 at the house
that means we need 180 out of the i
wouldn't sell the rental unless you just
don't like it
i just take that out of your stocks and
mutual funds and you choose
okay capital gains rates likely going up
next year if you cash out stuff this
year you may get a better rate
biden's trying to raise it and because
capital gains of course we all know is
how rich people get rich and that can't
happen and so he must be you must be
destroyed so um yeah that's coming it's
in the current vibe if i don't know if
you'll get it passed or not but i
suspect he will um
the biden administration i guess this is
whatever anyway but yeah so
i'm probably taking some capital gains
off the table
while you can do it at a 15 percent
capital gains rate we'll use for 180 000
worth which is going to be a lot of your
220.
um
but if you cashed out
all of your mutual funds and stocks and
paid all the taxes and had that pile of
money sitting on the table would you buy
other mutual funds and stocks or would
you uh pay off the house you'd pay off
the house we know that because you
called me and asked about it so you're
probably with taxes and everything going
to get rid of almost both the
twenty thousand dollars in cash and the
stocks and mutual funds that's probably
what i would do but i like rental
property if you hate the rental you can
sell the rental you can go either way
luanne's with us in iowa city hi luanne
how are you
oh my gosh star struck
me too what's up
okay so here's the thing this is not
really a math problem because the math
is kind of a duh
it's more of an emotional thing so i'm a
nurse
um obviously i have the option to go
travel
for upwards of around five thousand
dollars a week which is about three
thousand dollars more than i made this
week working 72 hours between my two
jobs yep
um
the concerns are my husband's a little
freaked out by it
because
i would be gone
approximately three to four days a week
in a row because the jobs are
not commutable but within a few hour
drive
my mom assists us with our six kids and
is very generous and does it for um
basically nothing
um
i think some of his concerns are
that for one we have amazing health
insurance through my jobs they're both
county rand jobs so i have state
insurance state retirement and very very
cheap health insurance
and also my only life insurance even
though i have pursued it
privately is through my job i've just
not been able to get it through my job
because
i had a health issue several years ago
that put us out and that was the one
brick in the wall that sent it all
crumbling and we had to file bankruptcy
but of course i got to keep my massive
student loans um that i think you just
made a documentary about me i watched it
so the question is
how do we make this decision how much
debt have you got
ninety three thousand except for the
house the house is a hundred the plan
would be you go on the road for how long
and then you come back home and land a
new nursing cake
in one year i could pay everything
including the house off okay
how old are you
i'm 42 okay and you have six kids from
three yeah from three to sixteen
and um we do homeschool a fair amount of
them but my mom is huge in helping with
that okay is she up for this for a year
yes she has been very supportive she
thinks it's silly that i'm working these
crazy hours
drive to des moines for she's the she's
the generation that worked their tail
off yeah okay
right she's like in two and a half hours
you can go to des moines you can work
your three nights and come home and be
home for four days
and
make twice the money three times the
money yeah
our local hospitals have done incentive
pay so it's basically an extra you know
forty dollars an hour which by the time
you figure benefits and stuff that's
essentially what the travel
pay is well the way i would look at it
is this if this was a permanent change i
couldn't sign up for it because of what
it would do to my family
it's not a permanent change it's a
one-year adventure
can we do can we can the kids
mom the husband and you
look at this like i'm gonna do this for
one year
and change our lives i've been praying
yeah we filed bankruptcy yeah and i feel
like god's like here it is yeah
i i had a lady on i had a lady do a debt
free scream uh just a couple months ago
that paid off 500 000 in one year
travel nurse coveted all she did was
work on the road and she paid off she
made a half a million dollars in one
year it was unbeaten believable i don't
think i can work all of the time i mean
you can't do that you're going back home
you're just doing 370 312's but uh and
getting k and getting a serious bonus
for doing it
i mean
hypothetically you could do 312's come
home and do some more from home
but uh right
that's that's that's asking a lot
yeah i have if everybody can line up on
this relationally it's not just the math
it's the sense of i'm impacting my life
for a short period of time
people are deployed for six months or a
year at a time all the time in the
military
there's lots of people who travel for a
living it happens all the time and if
you look at it as a short-term thing
for a long-term gain and everybody's
calling in an adventure do it but if
somebody's going to really squeal then
you probably don't do it
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
this is james childs a producer of the
ramsay show you can listen to all our
shows with the ramsay network app on
your smartphone browse by topic or even
sync clips to your friends
download the ramsay network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your
[Music]
story live from the headquarters of
ramsey solutions broadcasting from the
dollar car rental studios it's the
ramsey show where debt is dumb cash is
king and the paid off home mortgage has
taken the place of the bmw as the status
symbol of choice
merry christmas america we're glad
you're here open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five tis the
season for outrageous generosity if
you're not in a position to be
outrageously generous this is the place
to help you get there we want to get you
out of debt and on a plan so you got
some wiggle room baby and you know what
you do when you got a wiggle room
you wiggle
that's what you do
life is good open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five
danielle starts off this hour in reading
pennsylvania hi danielle how are you
hi there i'm good good what's up
my question is that i've been working on
my
snowball and
i am co-signed on some of my son's
student loans
and
i know this was before i knew better
so do i count that in my
snowball
yes ma'am because co-signing means if he
doesn't pay you do
yes that's what we call a contingent
liability in accounting class
and so um
now how much student loan debt does
said son have
that i am assigned to or cosigned on
it's um 38 000 co-signed with him and
then i do have my own parent plus loan
that's 19. so okay and what other debt
do you have
uh a car
and uh how much
i'm gonna i think it's about 22 000 left
on it
and then a
uh credit card that i've been i
consolidated and i'm paying it uh and
it's about 12 000 right now okay
and um
what's your household income
68 000.
okay
all right
and you're single how old are you
52. okay
all right
the car is pretty expensive it's not a
complete deal breaker but you got a lot
of other stuff you're peddling through
and
you know you got 60 000 before we get to
junior's loans
so how old is junior
25.
how's he doing financially
um pretty well uh
uh well i don't think i can say that he
does manage his money well and he makes
his payments every month um
right now i would say he probably
makes about
17 an hour and he just moved into his
first apartment
out of state actually so
you know he's doing his own grown-up
thing yeah okay
well the problem is if he doesn't do it
you get to because of the co-signing
yeah so that's why i was asking about
his uh health
financially um
well what i'm gonna do is put those at
the end of your deal
and while you're working through your
debt snowball you need to share your
story with him pretty regularly
so he starts to catch on that maybe he
ought to do this you don't need to call
him up every day and tell him he needs
to do it but you need to tell him all
about you
so you become an inspiration for him
okay and then after doing that for a
while you can say stuff drop in there
too like and i'm really worried about
these student loans they're bothering me
they're keeping me up at night those
that co-signing oh i wish i hadn't done
that i just feel so bad about it and let
him feel bad that his mama feels bad and
he gets his butt in gear and pays him
off
i'm not above i'm not above shaming him
into it okay because it's for his own
good by the way as soon as he gets his
tail and gear and starts making more
than 17 did he get the degree
he did and not even in in
professional writing
okay so he he was working for a digital
marketing company
for a while doing the writing thing and
a lot more than 17 dollars an hour then
well at the time
this was right out of
what as soon as he finished school and
so i i think that
it's a small business and the guy wasn't
quite that generous okay
well a digital marketing writer would
make a lot more than 17 an hour though
so i mean in the real world if he got
out here and did something let's see
right now what's he do now
he's working for fedex okay cool
all right and he also has a online
business that he does um like flipping
sneakers and things he's always been a
hustler he he definitely is making money
and wanted to start an actual brick and
mortar business doing that but i already
you know discussed with him there's not
a chance with all this student loan that
you're gonna be able to get you know
something so you really gotta work on
this but
i talked to somebody the other day about
a sneaker thing and the kid was
making a bazillion dollars so he made
like 60 000 bucks selling sneakers on
ebay oh yeah he
when he did live at home boxes were
coming and going every day it was a
serious amount of
moving going on there all right okay i'm
are you in financial peace university
i'm not okay i want you to go through
financial peace university i'm gonna
give you a ramsay plus membership
because i want i want our team to wrap
our arms around you give you a big hug
and help you walk through this
and i'm also going to give you one to
give to him as a gift
and you just call him up and you just
say hey listen i'm working this plan and
i'm so excited about it and i just want
you to know it's there and
and you know we could even do it
together virtually long distance or
whatever and uh you don't need to ever
wag your finger at him and shame him but
i want him to hear how inspiring you are
and how fired up you are and i want him
to see the same sets of information
you're seeing on how to do this so that
you can
uh
you know you can we can get him moving
along i think he might be making more
money than we think he's than you think
he's making and he needs to put it all
on the stinking student loan
so that you don't have to deal with it
ever like i want to paid off if he could
pay it off this year and make me happy
and then you don't have to worry about
it the faster he pays it off the quicker
it's off your books meanwhile we're
going to get you out of that so you hang
on i'm gonna have kelly pick up and
kelly ramsey plus for
uh junior and for mom yeah one for each
and let's get them in there and let's
get them through financial peace
university and uh learn how to do this
stuff then they can get on here and do a
a mother-son debt-free scream that would
just be awesomeness be about as good as
it gets
so here's the thing um if you if you if
you think student loans are a good idea
here's what i want you to do through the
holidays a lot of you have things you're
looking for something to watch during
the holidays
jump on apple tv
or uh
amazon prime or on uh
google play and watch borrowed future
our documentary
your mind
will come unglued from your
head you you just blow your mind
this this documentary on the evils of
the student loan world
and how out of control just about every
segment of that world is
will you know you'll never let a person
you know getting student loan debt again
if you see this
borrowed future full length documentary
by
ramsey networks we put it together here
and it's world class it's uh very well
done
several hundred thousand folks have
already viewed it we are stirring up a
holy ruckus with this thing
be sure you watch it through the
holidays borrowed future again apple tv
google play or prime video
uh you can catch it anywhere amazon
prime i mean and there you go don't miss
it it's what she's talking about this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much pure
talk gives you the same great 5g
coverage on the same 5g network as one
of the big guys for half the cost the
average family saves over 800 a year go
to puretalk.com and choose the
affordable plan that's right for you
with their 30-day risk-free guarantee
you have nothing to lose go to
puretalk.com and enter the promo code
ramsey to save 50 off your first month
[Music]
so
[Music]
open phones this hour this is the ramsey
show thank you for joining us america
just like we were talking with her about
her the way to get to a debt-free scream
the way to get control of your money the
way to be in a place to be outrageously
generous and become a baby steps
millionaire is financial peace
university
you can get that at ramsey plus just go
to ramsey solutions dot com slash fpu
ramsey solutions dot com slash fpu
bill is with us bill is in albuquerque
new mexico bill how are you
good how are you better than i deserve
what's up
well yeah um in fact i'm thinking about
taking my 401k and paying off my house i
owe like a little over like 150 000.
i've been retired for
20 years from law enforcement and
anyway just want to get completely debt
free i was wondering if that's a good
idea or not
well it's always a great idea to be debt
free um you called to that free show i
mean that's what we do here
um 150 grand gets you out how old are
you
i'm 65. okay how much is in your
retirement account
uh
well i have one my wife has one but so
mine is right around 240
249 250 right around there hers
uh hers
probably about 125
but my retirement that i get from the
state is totally different it's that's
the 401k is totally different i know
that you got a full pension from them
right and what's your income from the
pension
uh
right around 45 000
a year
yes
okay
and y'all are living on that
uh well i work also too oh what do you
make
i i work
i just started another job but i was
making like 75 000 a year
and then i just i just went down to
about 55
do something totally different
okay so i think right around 100 000 a
year
okay
uh
[Applause]
okay so you got 100 uh to 350 300
yeah so if you pull out um
like you're to start with you and your
wife own both of those accounts you
realize that even though it's in her
name right if something happened you've
got each other's beneficiaries and even
if there was a divorce you'd get half
she'd get half so
uh even though it's got one of his name
on it or the other one so i'm looking at
the total in retirement
as uh
being about four hundred thousand and
that sounds about right
yes
and if you cash out 150 of that it'll
cost you 200 you'd have 200 left plus
you've got 100 000 dollar your income
correct yeah i'd do that
okay and you don't have a house payment
anymore
correct yeah and i owe everything else
too so
also that's your only debt left is that
what you're saying that's my only debt
correct
yeah
very good very good well done well done
man yeah i'd do that i'd be out of debt
as soon as i could
thanks for calling in bill's with us in
charlotte north carolina hey bill
welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
uh i've got a whole life policy with a
unique situation i'm sorry uh it was
purchased in the early 90s
and i paid into it for four or five
years and then i found out there was a
class action lawsuit against the company
or uh deceptive sales practices
uh i i joined the class action suit and
part of that settlement was that well
the settlement was that
i no longer had to pay into it but the
face value was guaranteed until the day
i die
and my question is should i hold uh
should i continue to hold it or should i
turn it in for the surrender value which
is uh
the policy is about it was 300 for face
value
and the surrender value is about 80 000.
well here's what's going to happen
when you die
they're going to send your beneficiary
300 000 bucks
right
what happened to your 80 000
they keep it
so you really have 220 000 worth of
insurance
okay that you're paying 80 000
that you're paying 80 000 for
okay because if you took it out you'd
have 80 000
right that's right and how old are you
i'm 55. cool do you need insurance
yeah yeah right now yes okay are you
healthy but i can take down i can i'm
healthy overweight or smoke
uh a little overweight but i don't smoke
okay no hypertension that you know of
no okay
all right i mean you can buy 200 000
worth of 20-year level term
uh for nothing compared to 80 000 worth
of loss
my point is the free insurance is not
really free my brother
okay see what i'm saying
i do you put 80 000 in your pocket today
and buy
term life insurance until you don't need
it anymore for a couple of grand here or
there
and uh you know have 70 000 or 75 or 78
000 or whatever it is left plus whatever
that investment actually yields which it
ain't yielding nothing in that whole
life policy yeah i'm cashing it out
after i get my term life in place
great that's it that's what i was hoping
you would say yeah i wouldn't pay 80 000
bucks for a 220 000 term policy which is
in effect what's happening here boys and
girls
yeah
that's the problem
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five you jump in we'll
talk about your life and your money that
was an interesting question i've never
had one where they
had free insurance because of the
lawsuit but it's not free
the whole life business is um they got
sued for deceptive practices they all
should be sued for deceptive practices
the whole business is a deceptive
practice cory's in cincinnati hi corey
what's up
hi uh hi dave how you doing better than
i deserve how can i help yeah
thanks um so my wife and i are trying to
send our kids to private school we got a
four-year-old a two-year-old
and uh two-month-old and right now she's
staying home with him and i did the
calculation for her to go back to work
when the
when the two-month-old is in school it
cost us about 70 000 bucks
up to there for private school expenses
up to that point where she can start
working we break even on my salary um
and we're debt-free you know we've
always been debt-free but we're not
we're not like saving we break even so
she's got a
75 000
403 b
we were wondering i know you want us to
roll that out because she's not teaching
right now but we're wondering if we roll
that out
you know the best way to use that for
private school expenses i think we
probably have to take that tax kit you
can't you can't put it in the 529 right
away or you can't use it for private
school expenses
not even with the 10
you're going to get a 10 penalty plus
your tax rate you're borrowing money at
30 to 40 interest to send your kids to
private school that's dumber than a rock
you don't want to do that but my even
with my retirement completely good like
i'm thirsty you don't want to borrow
money at 30 or 40 interest to send your
kids to school man
that's just done private that's just
done yeah i know but okay but then what
else is our you know our option where i
feel like
that
that money is there it would it be 30 to
40 percent yeah you're gonna get hit 10
percent plus your tax bracket
which right now with three kids at home
i get money from the government it's
crazy with the tax write-off
uh you know i pay zero federal tax say
actually write me a check
on my 70k that i make let's just call it
here let's call it 20 percent
you want you want to borrow money at 20
interest to send your kids to school no
you don't
i mean you figured out how you want to
use this in your brain and there's no
talking you out of it apparently but
it's a dumb idea dude don't do it you
guys have got to adjust your budget
or you've got to adjust your
expectations it may be with three kids
and making 70 000 they're not in private
school
[Music]
ouch then we'll hear that because what
happens when the 401k that you cashed
out and took the hit on the chin is gone
or the 403b then you're really going to
be screwed because you've got to obvious
expectations set on private schools now
and you can't afford them anymore
because you don't make enough to send
them
to that school
without your wife working outside the
home
so some choices are going to have to be
made cashing this 403 b out is not going
to be the magical answer there's no
magic dust in that jack no not gonna
happen
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're ready to get out there and
find a job you love then you need to
hear this
job hunting can be stressful and time
consuming but my friends at ziprecruiter
have made the whole job search way
easier ziprecruiter is rated the number
one job site in the us by g2 and it's
free so how does it work first go to
ziprecruiter.com
ken then create a free profile and let
their technology do the hard work by
finding and sending you jobs that are a
great fit and get this
zip recruiter pitches your profile to
companies whose jobs match your skills
and experience if someone from that
company likes your profile they can
personally invite you to apply for the
job so if you're ready for an easier job
search check out ziprecruiter sign up
for free right now at ziprecruiter.com
ken that's ziprecruiter.com
ken sign up today absolutely free and
let zip recruiter work for you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt-free stage joe and ashley are with
us hey guys how are you hey dave hey i
love it way to go i'm looking at your
t-shirts man mortgage free by 33. that's
right you paid off your house we did
y'all are weird people very i love you
amazing i'm so proud of you where do you
all live greenville south carolina oh i
love greenville it's a great town very
cool how much debt did you pay off total
it was 253
170
got it and how long did that take you it
took us five and a half years all right
way to go and your range of income
during that time we started at around
135 we jumped up to 200 and now we're
back down to about 170. cool good for
you turn off the hard work once the
debt's gone exactly yeah what do you all
do for a living i'm an engineer i'm a
project manager all right way to go you
guys so what's this house worth
probably about 300 you know the market's
going crazy
isn't that fun yeah you're 33 and you
don't have paid for 300 000 hours you're
so whacked i love it
way to go you guys
oh man what got all this started five
years ago
so go ahead we were gifted an fpu class
and when we got engaged and uh we let it
set for about two years finally decided
on a whim hey we're gonna do this
probably not gonna change very much but
we went ahead and did it and we changed
everything i did my first budget and i
said we can't afford these whole life
payments and we just turned everything
upside down oh you got rid of a whole
life policy huh
right there in the middle of it there
you go and then game on knock out the
debt and then we're looking up there's
the mortgage and five and a half years
later you're done yeah we actually had
started we paid off student loans in a
car loan about 79 000 worth
saved up the emergency fund and the down
payment and then we sat down and we
bought a house and everybody said yay
and i said i now owe 174 000 and that's
more than i owed before
so we said it's time to start hammering
on that mortgage yeah okay and uh took
the next four years to do that so the
discomfort with debt continued yeah and
uh you said that's not okay i bought a
house but i bought a mortgage too
exactly yeah way to go you guys i'm so
proud of you
very very well done who are your biggest
cheerleaders outside the two of you uh
so our families have been extremely
supportive my sister is on her own
debt-free journey and we're hoping
she'll be here in the next year or two
and i want to give credit to my
grandparents we lost them both in the
past year
and they left us a little bit of money
that helped us to cross the finish line
with the
how much they leave you uh 30 000 wow
yeah
so when that house gets paid off
grandpa's just smiling from heaven they
would be thrilled i love it yeah that's
who he was yeah i love it very cool well
very very good you guys okay you've been
through financial peace university you
paid off everything you get the house
you got the emergency fund say we're
getting rid of the house and you get rid
of the house debt and you're on your way
to being a baby steps millionaire
tell folks what the secret is
to wealth the secret is to getting out
of debt you gotta get on a budget if
you're married you gotta do it with your
spouse get in control of your money you
gotta be content and uh not max out your
lifestyle live well within your means
and you gotta get passionate and fired
up that you are buying options who are
buying your freedom by paying down debt
yeah
so uh
did you come i mean while you're working
on the house i know you're a gazelle
intense on the first part but when
you're you get the house and then uh
that five year period or that four-year
period or whatever was left on the house
to knock it out um you did have you said
content sometimes people say well those
ramsey people they don't do anything
they don't dave ramsey doesn't want me
to have a life i want you have a life
you're 33 with a paid-for house and
almost me
so that's pretty good life but uh but
but during this time you weren't like
living in a cave and collecting lent no
no no we we ate
we took a vacation or two we took a
vacation okay all right what kind of
vacations did you take while you were
paying off the house some minor stuff
more visiting family and friends trying
to keep the costs down yeah and then
after we paid it off we went to arizona
oh good yeah good nice cool trip good
good so what's the next big thing now
that you're completely free what do you
want to do now
really whatever we want yeah yeah maybe
more vacations and just more options
with the future yeah you know you'll be
able to do almost anything and like i
said you're on your way to being baby
steps millionaires without a doubt
mathematically so
the contentment piece is a big deal the
bible says godliness with contentment is
great gain
i'm convinced contentment might be the
most powerful financial principle
uh that if you can be content you can do
almost all the other financial stuff you
can invest and give and get out of debt
and you know that's a big deal
did that change during this journey for
you
i'd say yeah i mean you kind of watch
your friends and everybody you know
rationalizing to me why they need a
better car my car is 325 000 miles on
you need a better car in the parking lot
i love carla
but carla needs to be retired dude you
paid off your house i love carla but she
served her purpose it's time to go on to
the next one is good
cool all right well that's the thing and
yeah so they were making fun of that and
for you it was just okay right it's
great it's a great car and i appreciate
what we have more i mean having a house
that's all ours i look at it differently
yeah
you know what's weird all these years
later i mean it's been decades for for
sharon and i since we stood in that same
place
but uh today
we've got you know nice cars and you
know whatever we want like that kind of
stuff it's kind of ridiculous our life
is but the weird thing is is i don't i
used to buy cars for what other people
think now i buy cars because i like them
yeah and that that really is that sounds
subtle and people go oh well i bought it
for no i really don't care what you
think i really don't care what you think
i bought that i drive a raptor because
it's a bad truck you know i love that
raptor man i love that truck and so it's
my daily driver and uh i didn't buy it
because you thought it's cool you know i
just like that truck and it's different
so poor carla she's she's moving on now
and you need to you need to buy a car
not for somebody else but for you you've
earned it brother i'm so proud of y'all
very very cool
how does it feel to have no
payments it feels really good it's kind
of surreal at first you just kind of
make the last payment a couple weeks
later a letter shows up in the mail you
know you don't get the streamers but i
guess that's why we're here
so
there's a lot of breathing room in our
budget
digital streamers
yeah very cool well good job you guys we
got a copy of the baby steps
millionaires book for you it comes out
in january but i know a guy i'm going to
get you an early release copy because i
think you're right on your way that's
the next chapter in your story for sure
how ordinary people built extraordinary
wealth and how you will too you can too
uh and a copy of total money makeover to
give away pay it forward to somebody
because i know you've been talking about
this stuff somebody needs that book
and uh you probably got somebody in mind
you can give it to so well done you guys
very well done
very fun joe and ashley greenville south
carolina they're heroes 33 years old
they don't have a mortgage or
anything a hundred percent debt-free 253
thousand dollars paid off in five and a
half years making 135 to 200 to 170
count it down let's hear a debt free
screen three two one
this is how it's done boys and girls
yeah baby i love it
you want to know how to get rich
that's how you get rich
they're on their way you want to be in a
position you can help other people with
money that's how you do it right there
there's a lot of people out there
there's a lot of get-rich-quick going on
right now
nothing down real estate's booming
people are trying to get rich and
nothing down real estate taking on a
bunch of debt
people are
buying single stocks and they you know
they're out there buying crypto and
they're trying to get rich quick some
way or another
i got a big announcement are you all
ready
we're going to do
a huge event january the 13th george
campbell rachel cruz and me
building wealth
in 2022.
we're going to show you how to really
build wealth this is not pie in the sky
it's not microwave
it's crock pot
and if you ever had any food out of a
microwave and you had food out of a
crock pot you can tell me which tastes
better
and which will turn out most of the time
that microwave stuff's rubbery you all
know what i'm saying it just it's chewy
so we're gonna do this january the 13th
here in nashville we only have a
thousand tickets oh wait it was on the
internet overnight i'm sorry oh no
they're almost gone if you want to come
tickets are a whole fifteen dollars
uh there's going to be about a thousand
folks here
at the event
january the 13th here in nashville a one
night special event discover the money
plan that'll help you live the life you
want go to ramseysolutions.com
events you can get your tickets right
now
this instant that you're hearing this is
the first time that i've said this on
the air publicly and so this won't be
these tickets will be gone very quick 15
tickets are like stocking stuffers right
thursday january 13th
it's the wealth building event
building wealth the real way
for 2022 january 13th here in nashville
i'll see you there
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
open phones this hour i'm dave ramsey
your host thank you for joining us
so there is quite a rage out there i i
have noticed several times in my life a
an ebb and flow of the get rich quick
stuff
uh the infomercials came on the scene in
the 80s
and midnight television was completely
clouded with people sitting by the ocean
selling you a nothing down real estate
course
get rich quick was everywhere there's
been get rich quick it comes and goes
depending on the
the psychology of the culture what's
going on with the culture other times we
bear down and we say okay i'm going to
hustle and grind and i'm going to be the
tortoise other times we want to be the
hare
and we want to just run run run run run
run run go in circles and chase our tail
and
and um right now there is a protect you
know sometimes
get rich in multi-level marketing right
that was a big thing in the 90s and
various times that has popped up and
been a big deal
and people have made some money in
multi-level they made some money and
nothing down real estate they made some
money in crypto
but but in none of those cases is it
normative meaning it is a high
probability process that you're going to
end up wealthy
but it's tapping into a spirit of i want
to hit the easy button
and um i got to tell you i've been in
this a long long time now
and i really want you to be wealthy
so that you can have a quality life and
so that you can help other people with
the generosity
um
yeah i mean wow we just did
i mean the money we spend around ramsey
on christmas
just on blessing our team members and
the
the christmas party itself is
unbelievable and all of that happens
because we have the money and the the
charity acts that and ministries were
able to support all through the
community and things we were covering a
bunch of them in our staff meeting this
morning it's just amazing
just amazing
and and so it's um
you know it it it's something for you to
think about about what is
what is smoking mirrors what sounds too
good to be true because if something
sounds too good to be true it's because
it is too good to be true or what really
works
and really that's why i ended up doing
this book baby steps millionaires i
haven't done a book in eight years
we promoted and launched books with our
ramsey personalities but i haven't done
one since rachel and i did smart money
smart kids together and it was the
number one best seller
and so
baby steps millionaires how ordinary
people build extraordinary wealth and
how you can too
is a full-on a detailed plan and the
math is there
the research is there from the ramsey
millionaire study the stories are there
and even all of the things that people
tell you why you can't be wealthy in
america are addressed
you can do this and i can show you how
that's what this book is about
and you can get it for 20 bucks and if
you order it now
you'll get over 150 worth of bonus items
the audio books the e-books including
the legacy journey audio and e-book as
well
you're going to get tickets to events
you're going to get all kinds of things
when you buy this book
now in advance as a pre-purchase it
actually comes out january the 11th baby
steps millionaires ramsey solutions.com
just hit our store and you can pick it
up there katie is with us katie's in
grand rapids michigan hi katie how are
you
i'm good how are you done better than i
deserve what's up um so my husband and i
are 30 years old um we typically save
between 20 and 30 thousand dollars a
year
and we've kind of just been yeah um but
we've kind of just been holding on to
that cash we're in the middle of a
fixer-upper we
talked daily about starting a business
um that type of thing
but we had purchased the house um when
we first got married that we had turned
into a rental
um before the pandemic and then with the
the
um
increase in the real estate market we
over double their money by selling it
so we paid off the mortgage of the fixed
upper house that we're living in now
right and we still have yeah we still
have about a hundred thousand dollars in
cash though which is an excellent
problem to have yeah really but no i
know i'm not complaining but um now we
don't really know what to do with it so
you are 100 debt
absolutely you don't have a debt on
anything anywhere you don't you own one
piece of real estate that's a
fixer-upper
yep what's it gonna take to fix it
um so we've done most of the work
ourselves um and we're a good chunk of
the way like the main floor is all done
just like trim and stuff um at this
point it's mostly just cosmetic we
finally have a bathroom and again what
will it take to finish it
um
it will probably take
about
i don't know 10 to 15 10 to 15 grams of
just random stuff trim is not going to
be cheap but that type of thing okay
all right here's the thing i would use a
little bit of your cash to speed up your
process and get finished
yeah
living in a fixer living in a
fixer-upper is uh emotionally draining
absolutely
especially more for you than him because
guys can live under a bridge
i know but it's difficult to have
christmas and a fixer-upper i mean it's
just
the sawdust smell is it's cute for a
while but after a while it's just
sawdust can you tell i've done this so
uh yeah
so one of the failures of my life and my
marriage but anyway yeah so
here's the thing go ahead and spend some
money you made a little money you don't
have to go crazy but it's time to turn
up the schedule
with a little money so here's what i'm
gonna do
you told me 15.
i'm gonna say set aside 25 to 30 000 of
this money over to the side
and get your budget redone and finish
the stinking house
now
now
okay
does that feel good
yeah good now then you got 70 000 left
over to do some other stuff what's some
other things you need to do are you
needing to buy a car you need to do
something are you just going to invest
it and give it
um we probably do need to buy at least
um one new vehicle um we both and we've
never purchased anything good it's time
yeah you guys have been living on the
cheap for a long time and that's a good
thing because it got you where you are
and i'm not suggesting you act like
you're spending like you're in congress
but i am suggesting if you've earned the
right to drive a decent car and finish
your stinking house
all right so let's do so this is
investing into your the quality of your
life
and the difference you're driving a
three thousand dollar car right
yep the difference in a three thousand
dollar car in a ten thousand dollar car
is substantial
okay in terms of qual your quality of
life your dependability your creature
comforts you're not going crazy i didn't
say go buy a fifty thousand dollar car i
said buy ten thousand dollar cars three
times more car than you got now
so what i want you to do is go through
your life and say all right
we've been living life at a two out of
ten
and what i'm doing is through this
conversation together is i'm dialing it
up to a five out of ten
not a seven out of ten or a nine point
nine out of ten
okay i'm just dialing your lifestyle up
a little bit and the difference of the
quality of your life within six months
of doing all these things you're gonna
see substantially oh and here's what's
weird you're gonna prosper even more
financially
because when you're not working on a
stinking house and a broken down car
your brain is freed up to work on your
life
yeah
okay and that's why we do all this stuff
so i want you to enjoy some of this
money with a little bit of turn up the
lifestyle knob a couple of clicks here
on the cars
the eating out a little bit maybe a trip
is in in the future and then the rest of
it we can invest
and start thinking about buying another
property that we pay cash for and we
don't live in
and live in the nice one that you just
got finished
so i am not suggesting
that you go crazy here but i am
suggesting that your frugality and your
your care and your cheapness has earned
you the right and put you in a position
to
get the quality of your life increased
and the weird thing is is that will
actually cause you to prosper
so that's the thing
how many of us know that the
when you're broke your life looks like a
country song
i mean i've been there
it's like
the worst part i mean when when nothing
is going right is when the old car won't
start
the stinking alternator's out
the stupid batteries corroded
this is how i mean this up but but
whenever but if you get just a little
bit better car
because you save up and you've gotten
yourself out of debt and you're moving
along like they've done they've done
such a good job aren't they an
impressive people that was impressive
and you move up to a decent car that
when you put the car in the ignition or
you push the little button whatever you
do nowadays
the thing just starts it's magical wow
what's that noise yeah it's fun it gives
you the quality of your life goes up
this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
so
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host thank
you for joining us open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five
825-5225
andrew is with us in kansas city hi
andrew welcome to the ramsay show merry
christmas
merry christmas to you dave thanks for
taking my call sure what's up
yes i have a question for you i own my
own business creating websites and i
just had a question on business
insurance one is it necessary
and two if so what should i look for and
what should i us avoid
well there would be two things you might
cover with business insurance but
probably won't in your situation
one would one would be liability are you
doing something that would cause someone
harm building a website
uh no
i just
was just trying to think of all the
different ways that i can
be protected and as well as i mean if
you're doing something that someone
might sue you for screwing it up
because you bring them harm but
typically building a website or doing a
marketing plan or
stuff like that i mean there's no
liability
possible
okay
okay uh we do have an umbrella policy um
personally but i don't know if that yeah
that's just personal business now this
would be if you you know if you uh uh
did something and let's just make up
something that's not going to happen but
i mean you you wrote a program for their
website and it burned down their
building
you know or it's
smoked their their 200 000 server
because of your programming which really
is not possible i'm making this up and
you can't those neither one of those
things are physically possible to occur
so but if you could do something that
would
uh that would cause liability if harm
physical harm or something like that
then you would think about i don't think
i would do it if i were in your shoes i
don't think i'd worry about it the
second kind of insurance is if you've
got a big enough operation where you've
got overhead
and um
you wouldn't
to where if something happened and you
didn't have the cash you would uh you'd
have to lay off all your employees and
you couldn't pay your rent and pay your
light bill
that would be business interruption
insurance
okay and so if there was a a major
outage a uh a storm that tore up
something and you'd you know like if a
tornado came through you would you know
we just had some massive storms this
week
and um in america and so uh
god bless the mess and the poor people's
lives and the whole thing but but but
from a business perspective you know
yeah you've got insurance to build the
building back but in the meantime you're
not doing business you don't have income
coming in and so that interruption and
all of those employees don't have jobs
anymore because you can't cover it
and so um
that that's the whole thing and um
i think um
and again you're like a one-man shop
right
yeah just my wife and i yeah
you don't need business interruption
insurance right so you're fine i would
just let it ride
okay great i think your liability
insurance now if you get a bigger
operation and you're worried about
either one of those things the liability
of getting sued or
and there's something you can buy
insurance for uh then that's fine or
there may be other ways to
to to keep that out one thing i would do
when you get to some size i wouldn't
fool with it now but i would go ahead
and shift the business to an llc
when you're uh when you get some size on
it that it might be a target
sure because that way they can only get
what the llc has if the llc mis the
things that the business of the llc
misbehaved in some way you could lose
only that asset and like your personal
stuff no one could get through to that's
called piercing the corporate veil in
order for them to do that so good
question thank you for joining us man
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five jeff is in
cincinnati hi jeff how are you
hi dave how are you i'm good good how
can i help
dave um i'm 51 years old um
i work in a dying industry and
we are going to our plan is going to
shut down and at the latest it's going
to open is 2027 but it could shut sooner
than that
i'm debt-free
but i don't have a lot
saved for retirement
just wondering what i should do
so that i can retire
visa
well uh you're probably going to be
working more than five more years if you
have a zero save for retirement
right but but
i mean
um i i make a good living i
rose about 165 000 a year okay um
so what are you gonna do when the plant
shuts down in five years
well i was planning on what i was
planning on doing is
um
starting a greenhouse
and working for myself
okay
right and what can you make doing that
where i live probably
[Applause]
in the neighborhood of
forty thousand fifty thousand a year
substantial drop from one sixty five
yes
okay
so that's really going that's not going
to really assist you in building a nest
egg because you're telling me you have
no nest egg right
well i have i mean my home's paid for i
have eight and a half acres of land
that's paid for
but you don't have any money invested in
a nest egg for retirement
i got i got a small pitch and probably
it'll be about 50 000 a year but you
don't have any money invested in
retirement
no not a whole lot 20 000 in a 401k okay
all right so since you have no bills
and you have five years with this
fabulous income
let's turn up the heat man
max out max out your 401k
max out your roth iras are you married
yes
okay what's she make
she she's she doesn't work she has a lot
of health issues okay she make 165 000
max out two
individual roth iras max out your 401 k
that's about 40 000 bucks a year right
there
okay and and and let's just turn up the
heat and let's see how much money we can
get saved in the next five years i mean
let's just pretend that you saved uh 50
000 bucks for five years that'd be 250
000
in your in your retirement account when
you when the plant shuts down
okay and while you're at it you need to
pile up enough cash to build this
greenhouse for cash
all right over the next five years so
you need you got two goals here that you
need to budget for and you need to
really lean in on that so here's the
thing
if you put 250 000 in there you don't
ever save anything else
every seven years or so it will double
if it's in good mutual funds
okay and so let's see you said you're 51
5 years of 56
so at 63 it'll be 500
at 70 it'll be a million
all right but you need that 250
in there in the next five years so you
need to say 50 000 or more a year start
with maxing out all your retirement get
with our smartvestor pro in your area
and get this game plan laid out you've
done a really good job of putting some
basic assets in your life that paid for
real estate stuff that's amazing now
let's put some cash in there to eat with
my man and you'll be in much better
condition uh attitude wise when this
plant goes shutting down on you
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Music]
thank you for joining us america open
phones this hour at triple eight eight
two five five two two five one of the
things going around america right now is
get rich quick has kicked into gear
again
periodically we go through a get rich
quick phase in our culture and we're in
the middle of one
people are looking for quick easy ways
to become wealthy and those are always
fraught with danger but nothing down
real estate has
popped up again as a way to get rich
quick and you can get rich quick but
you'll go broke quick in it too
um any way you can shortcut anything
having to do with money a lot of people
buying bitcoin on that same premise
they're going to get rich and easy it's
no problem and if you don't understand
you're just not up with technology you
will stupid boomer and all that stuff
right so here's the thing
we're gonna do an event here in
nashville
on how to build wealth in 2020 building
wealth in 2022
2022. me rachel cruz george camel
january the 13th we put the tickets on
sale today
uh half of them are already gone
it only the venue only holds just about
a thousand folks and so it will fill up
very very quickly tickets are only they
start at just 15 and they go up from
there but
join us in nashville it's a one night
special event
and we're gonna show you
a proven
plan how to really build wealth this
year
not what somebody's opinion is that
lives in their mother's basement and has
a financial blog
this is a proven process
that for 30 years we've shown people how
to become millionaires
and they have by the way become
millionaires
so if you'd like to join us for that
live event here in nashville
if you're up for being in a room with a
thousand plus people
rachel cruz and george campbell will be
with me on january the 13th here in
nashville at our building wealth in 2022
event
go to
ramseysolutions.com and get your tickets
right now
ramsey solutions dot com
slash events
and get your tickets for this building
wealth event again i don't think these
tickets will make it to the end of the
week
and uh so i'm pretty sure they won't
they're half gone already and we just
put it up today
so we did a little bit of pre-marketing
on the internet it took a bunch of them
so anyway jump in
get your tickets now while you can
open phones at triple eight eight two
five
two
candace is with us she's in austin texas
hi candace how are you
i'm blessed steve how are you doing
better than i deserve what's up
yeah i was just calling hoping to get
your opinion um you helped my husband
and i before we
got married to get out of debt um and
we've been out of debt for the last
five and a half years
yeah thanks it's all thanks to you and
your program so
um but we're kind of at a city situation
we bought our home about four and a half
years ago
and
all of our extra money is aside from
retirement savings that we've been
putting into a mutual fund
and then we have some stocks and so we
built up enough now that we could go and
pay off our mortgage
and we're just trying to decide if
that's the best move to make knowing
that
this is going to be a rental home
okay um
well let's go back to the part where you
said you've been following our process
and you use that to get out of debt
okay um you mean you loosely generally
know what we teach or somehow you
have plugged into details of what we
teach
no i mean i definitely can
can plug in the details we have our
so you know my answer to your question
then
i mean i think that we should pay it off
i mean what would i mean
if you ever heard me in any of our
teachings say anything else
no never one time did i tell people to
build up money into a mutual fund and in
single stocks to pay off their mortgage
i told them to just pay off their
mortgage
does that sound familiar
yeah no i mean we we put the money into
to mutual funds rather than just having
it in a savings account but
i understand um i understand what i'm
saying is
what i'm trying to understand is um
uh
i mean i i think we inspired you to get
out of debt but you never really got
down into the details of exactly what we
teach in the baby steps and how to do it
because you wouldn't have done what
you've done if you understood that if
you were following our stuff which you
said
because we don't teach people to do what
you've done we teach them to pay off
their house
and so now that you've done it though
you've got the money yes i'd pay off
your house today
now then you've got a paid for house
wait a minute you said rental which
means you're going to sell that or
you're going to move to another house
and take out a mortgage
yes well we want to
our plan is to
then
buy
snowball money to buy
a piece of land to build our home on
with cash
or are you going to take out a mortgage
to build your home
well you're going to take out a mortgage
to build it okay
i want you to have rental property again
you're welcome to do whatever you'd like
to do candice you're you're obviously an
adult you get to make your choices
you called and asked me what we would do
and what we teach okay so let's go back
baby step
four is 15 of your income going into
retirement after you're out of debt and
have your emergency fund in place does
that sound familiar
yes okay and five is to take care of
kids college and six is you put
everything else on the house until it's
paid off
okay then if you're going to buy other
properties you save and pay cash for
them if you can't you need to sell the
other house
so
i don't think you're going to follow
what i teach but i'll go ahead and tell
you what it is
because it's so different from your plan
but what we teach is and i'll tell you
why we teach it so you understand the
why too but um what we teach is i would
take all of the money that you've got
today and i'd pay off your house
i would pile up cash as high as i could
pile it up and if you're unable to
build the property on the piece of land
without borrowing money then i would
sell this other house in order to pay
cash for my residence because having
your residence paid off
and a paid for are having a residence
mortgage with a pay with a paid off
rental property that makes no sense at
all
so what i would tell you to do is get
your residence paid off wherever that is
through whatever message or method we're
going to use here and then
i would start saving and pay cash for my
first rental but in no case am i going
to tell you to borrow any more money in
all of these scenarios so if i woke up
in your shoes
i would pay cash i would take the money
out and i would pay off your mortgage
today
then i would pile up more cash and when
i got ready to buy the land and build
the property i would sell the current
residence
pay cash for your new place with the
saved money and the sale of your current
residence
and then you'd have a paid for nicer
place on acreage
now you've got no bills in the world
let's pile up cash and go buy a rental
somewhere
but i'm not going to try to back into
the rental now i don't think you're
going to do that but that's how i would
do it by the way that's how i
did it and it worked fabulously
but it requires a little more patience
on buying the rental you're trying to do
about six things at one time here you
want to have investments you want to
have a paid off house and you want to
have a paid off rental and you want to
build a house out in the country and on
the land and so you've get you can't be
doing all these things at one time
you're building it's going to catch up
with you
so the good news is you've saved some
money and you've got some options now
the only question is what you're going
to do
from this point forward and you've got
to make that decision i can't make that
for you
thank you for the call
open phones at triple eight eight two
five
five two two five if you want to know
what the baby steps that we teach are
exactly and exactly how to follow them
in detail
that's what the best selling book the
total money makeover is it's on sale for
ten dollars right now
people buy them by the case and give
them away as gifts
but in great detail
exactly how people have become baby
steps millionaires the shortest distance
between where you are and wealth is all
in the total money makeover
[Music]
do
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage rick and laura are with
us hey guys how are you good good happy
to be here merry christmas where do you
all live
we live in kingsburg california ah cool
good to have you and all the way to
tennessee to do a debt-free scream
that's right how much have you paid off
we paid off seventy four thousand fifty
two dollars and thirty two cents
excellent how long did this take you
took us seven years and eight months
we were turtles dave okay
and uh your range of income during that
seven years
we started out at 44 000 and we ended up
at 72. okay cool very cool what kind of
debt was your 74 000 well most of it was
our student loans we had 55 000 in
student loans we had uh just over 14 000
in credit card and then we had another 4
500 in a family loan ah okay all right
cool so what puts you on this journey
tell us your story
well we came to a church in uh dainuba
california near kingsburg and part of
the process of of coming on staff as
associate pastor at the time uh was to
take the financial piece university
class oh wow and i thought uh yeah
that's a little intrusive
um who's this pastor think he is making
us take this finance class
but from the day one that we took that
class we knew this is exactly what we
needed totally changed our financial
perspective and the rest and as a pastor
that was hard to admit you know i'm
supposed to have all that together
so
i understand i understand cool so you
began the journey and it was a slow long
slog huh
yep
yeah we uh during that time we cash
flowed three children we had already had
our oldest emma at the time she was
almost two
and um so he paused for nine months each
time and then threw it all at debt after
each pregnancy so that took a little bit
of time
and then in the last year we ended up
paying off about thirty four thousand
dollars oh my gosh most of it in one
year yeah the last eight months yeah we
ended up paying off thirty four thousand
the last eight months of our debt free
journal what accelerated us so much
uh that snowball and um
checks from the government and uh yeah
what else we didn't use any of those
checks for ourselves yeah we just kept
throwing it all at debt but that that
raise and income happened at the end too
but also just getting a little more
gazelle intense at that time
through our debt free journey too we we
went through seven different beater cars
uh some of those were gifts we went
through crowns and root canals we went
through two different moves and uh just
had a lot of things like that going on a
lot of life a lot of life happened but
you didn't quit didn't quit no and then
at the end your hockey stick up and to
the right that's right boom just go
yeah look at that way to go guys how
does it feel to be free
wonderful
absolutely wonderful wonderful good job
guys we wouldn't trade it for anything
yeah fabulously done love it love it
love it so proud of you thank you and
you brought the kiddos with you what are
their names in the ages bring them up
all right come on up girls we have uh
emma constance bonnie and holly
emma is ten
constance right here is seven bonnie is
four and holly is 15 months oh here we
go okay cool what do you tell people the
secret to getting out of debt is now
that you've done it be consistent don't
give up yeah your steadiness is what did
it that's right and the borrower is
slave to the lender but uh our only
master is christ amen
amen and now you're free yeah that's
right congratulations guys i'm so proud
of you who are your biggest cheerleaders
outside of you guys
uh family friends uh wayne and debbie
pettnack my parents marco and malie my
sister melissa brother thomas
sister-in-law matt oh a lot of
cheerleaders uh rick's mom and dad
carmen we had a lot of help along the
way my mom gave us the total money
makeover gave me that back when i was in
college and i thought yeah who's this
guy i'm the that that book collected
dust i never read that got it
until we took the class and then i
realized how right my mom was yay i love
it yes well congratulations you guys i'm
so proud of you heroes well done how's
it feel to be free
so good how does it feel girls
good
they've been waiting for this for a long
time this one in particular she's yeah
she was the one that was freaking out
when we started seven years yeah she's
had a lot of practice but been ready to
go all right rick and laura emma oh we
got a copy of i'm sorry baby steps
millionaire for you that's the next
chapter in your story put you in a
position to be outrageously generous and
of course uh total money makeover you
can give it to somebody so they can
collect dust that'd be perfect i love it
all right
rick and laura emma constance bonnie and
holly 74 000 paid off in seven years and
eight months making 44-72
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
three two one we're debt-free
[Applause]
way to go you guys
that is exactly how it's done that is
fabulously done well done well done well
done chris is with us in detroit
michigan hi chris welcome to the ramsay
show
hi dave thanks for having me sure what's
up
uh so my question is um me and my
girlfriend are looking to get married uh
in the next few years here
um and we don't really have a ton of
money or assets to do that with
neither of us has any debt but we're
wondering
what we can do
um with like
like a wedding coming up um maybe a
house or rental or whatever we do
what kind of um
money we should have saved before we try
to go ahead with getting married
how old are you
20.
and what do you do for a living
currently
i'm a manager at a fast food joint um
i've been applying a lot to get
something in my field
um
what is your feel i have
bioengineering
and you have a four-year degree
uh not yet i'm working on the last year
of it okay
all right
all right cool
and uh yeah that would certainly pay
more than managing a fast food operation
right
yeah it should yeah what do you make now
um
15 an hour okay what does she make
uh hers is a little spottier um
she's in school right now for nursing
um and she's doing clinicals and we'll
be doing
further more like paid
um whatever it's called when will she
graduate
she'll graduate
um in 2023
okay
all right and you live with your parents
she lives with hers or what
yep
okay
all right when are you thinking of
getting married
um honestly as soon as possible but we
didn't want to be reckless about it
either okay
well i think if you're going to do it as
soon as possible you have a very minor
uh low budget wedding
which there's no shame in by the way
lots of people have low budget weddings
and have wonderful lives
uh you know you know there's no
correlation between the expense of the
wedding and the success of the marriage
no statistical evidence of that okay nor
the size of the ring in the marriage
uh so um i mean you guys can lay that
out and say okay we're gonna budget for
this and then we're gonna get a little
apartment and we're gonna put some used
furniture in it
and uh we're gonna be able to pay our
bills with the work that we have
and we're gonna have to work extra jobs
and you know make do things to make ends
meet but you're not buying a house right
now you're gonna get her through nursing
school and we're gonna get you in your
career long term
but um
i mean if you can work 60 hours at 15
and she can work uh
some hours and keep going while she's
going through nursing school you can
probably pay for a little apartment and
you know just get started with your
lives and have a low budget wedding
again some family and friends and pick
some flowers out of the field right
um put cook some hamburgers on the grill
it does not really you know
being married does not require a big
fancy you don't spend a hundred thousand
dollars to get married it's not
necessary uh if you want to you can
but um but but not
um
not otherwise so uh it just depends on
again so i and the way you do this is
you just back in you say okay uh it's uh
it's christmas we want to get married in
september
and between now and then we got to save
up the money to pay our deposits on an
apartment uh get utilities turned on we
have to work our budgets out make sure
we can do that and we've got to save up
some money to have whatever level of
wedding we're gonna have and you start
laying it out and you go okay we can
save 200 a month and that's nine months
so we can have you know a couple
thousand dollars to spend on a little
wedding and you lay it out that way
figure out what you can do and back into
the goals
and then you can decide you know what
your timeline is that's reasonable so
hey good question man hope it works out
for you this is the ramsey show
[Music]
our scripture of the day proverbs 22 29
do you see someone skilled in his work
they will serve before kings they will
not serve before officials of low rank
andy warhol said making money is art and
working is art and good business is the
best art
i like it
andy warhol who knew
wouldn't thunk it very cool open phones
here at triple eight eight two five five
two two five dave is with us in orlando
florida hi dave how are you
uh well i think better than i deserve
good good how can i help
well dave are you in a good mood today
i'm working on it merry christmas what's
up
merry christmas so i'm about to ruin it
for you i'm going to get on one of your
favorite topics
my father-in-law died about seven years
ago and i've been doing the been doing
the debt snowball and everything i'm
getting there getting close to uh that
uh debt-free zone and lo and behold we
got a christmas card in the mail this
past week of a lawsuit from a time share
company they want my uh wife and her
heirs to pay six thousand dollars in
back dues fees and assessments for a
timeshare that used to belong to my
deceased uh father-in-law that nobody in
this family has used cares anything
about her once ever since he passed away
what do we do about that was there an
estate with assets
there is an estate with assets and the
assets are held in trust there was a
living will or a a living trust that was
done and my wife is the trustee uh along
with my but they sued you personally
they sued them personally yes all three
of the siblings of his siblings have all
three been sued personally did they
receive assets from something other than
the trust was their or their assets
outside the trust
no
nothing has come to them outside of the
trust what's the size of the estate
uh the estate holds nothing in it any
longer but the home what was the truth
how much was in the trust originally uh
and the trust originally was a home and
a rental property the rental property
was sold for about 160 000
last year and used to pay off a second
mortgage it was on the main home
and
then there was ten dollars and that's
what was in the in the estate completely
okay here's why i'm asking all right
when you die what you own
stands good for what you owe
okay and so let's just pretend there was
no trust involved and they had benefited
from this and not paid off the time
share
and not paid the time share fees then uh
technically under contract law you'd
probably lose the lawsuit in this case
the estate
uh is all in a trust so it is all
probably protected from them
you're certainly not personally liable
unless you personally received assets
from the estate which you did not you
received assets from the trust
right
so i'm not i'm not an attorney but when
you talk to one that's what they're
going to tell you so how does the fee
simple thing work how can
time shares just say you own this fee
simple in perpetuity no you're
you're you're well you you don't your
wife didn't but her father did
right okay and her father had a contract
with them and that contract has to be
paid off
um
during the estate being closed out
however this estate had no assets in it
except a trust all of which is protected
from other debtors so let's say that
there was a a credit card debt right
okay
uh normally if you sold the house off
and it was not in a trust you'd have to
do that but the trust is not liable for
that credit card debt right because it's
not the same entity as her as her father
so anyway technical details but you need
to talk to an attorney obviously which
company is this
uh it i don't know what company it is
it's a timeshare here in florida up in
uh central florida yeah the lawsuit
didn't have a company name on it uh it
has an attorney that's representing
this particular timeshare yeah usually
this is not like an rci or something
like that it's an individual
uh timeshare unit
okay all right yeah yeah i would i would
get an attorney and i would beat the
snot out of these scum burgers
yeah
i thought that you'd enjoy it because
they're some of the most upstanding and
honest people in the world or time share
uh yeah they're they're just absolute
crooks i mean that the business is just
a horrible horrible business
and you should people you should just
stay away from but here's the thing your
wife here's what you need to separate in
your mind your wife is not personally
liable for the you know any of her
father's debts
including a debt to a time share company
what is liable is the estate
and the only question is uh whether or
not so if your wife took
and her sisters took 20 000 bucks or 30
000 bucks out of a cd that was in his
name and not in a trust sure and didn't
pay his bills yeah the credit card
company that he didn't that you didn't
pay could come after them
i understand that that's what that's the
premise they're using to come after you
what they what they're not apparently
informed of is the fact that the estate
didn't have any assets
yeah they're suing for foreclosure
yeah oh we would love for them to
foreclose
yeah well they're trying to foreclose on
my wife and her and my uh
right that's what they're trying to do
trying to foreclose on them in this suit
yeah they don't own it you can't
foreclose on me if i don't own it you
could say you could sue me for
foreclosure on that time share i don't
own it
right and that's what that was what my
question to you was how can they sue
them i'm i'm afraid well i mean you can
sue anybody for anything you can just
make up crap and file lawsuits
it's happened to me i mean you can just
make up stuff and just lie you know and
basically that's what the timeshare
company's doing here they're just trying
to collect on something because they
smelled that this estate's got some
money in it and they didn't get paid
right and that's what that's what
they're coming after um and so
you know it just depends on how much
money you want to spend on principle on
this but uh you're probably going to
drop 10 grand
yeah to to go punch them in the nose and
that's what it's going to take and if
you need some help with this there's an
attorney that comes on here periodically
that hates the timeshare business as
much as i do
and he he beats him up all the time for
a living his name is scott montgomery in
springfield missouri
okay write that down and call scott and
tell him what's going on he can he can
probably make an example out of these
boys he's pretty tough and he knows his
stuff he's sharp he comes on the air
here with me uh to comment on the the
scum burgers and the timeshare business
all the time scott montgomery
springfield missouri there's timeshare
attorneys all over america that fight
the timeshare companies sure but he's
one that i just know of right off the
top of my head that you could get a hold
of him and you're going to have to have
somebody defend you or counter sue
right as your defense mechanism and
um the other thing you could do is you
could file all kinds of complaints there
in florida
right with the state government the
different uh the commerce department and
other things for a faulty false lawsuit
and um yeah i would light them up
personally but it just depends on how
much hassle and what you want to go
through
uh you may be able to write them a check
for 5000 bucks and they go away
but um
but you know i don't know uh you that
probably is the more expedient thing to
do but you're dealing with scum
and it just gets your blood boiling and
makes you want to spend 25 000 to make
sure they get nothing
um
yeah i mean i've spent millions of
dollars on these things to make sure
that people get nothing
and i'll continue to do it just because
i'm that guy and i need a hobby you know
but um but some people don't want fool
with all that stuff and it is a pain in
the butt i'll tell you that so but you
do you do want to you have to stand up
sometimes and just say that's it i'm
done i'm not taking this anymore i'm not
gonna like be lied about cheated stolen
from and not and not caught and call it
so
you you decide which which hill you want
to fight on because you're gonna fight
on one someday
hey good question man we appreciate you
joining us
open phones this hour this is the ramsey
show
and it's just one more instance of how
scummy the timeshare business is
don't go in the tiger cage
don't go in the tiger cage don't go in
there for the free dinner
the free
passes to wally world
the free
night stay at the resort
and then get pressured by some half butt
guy who couldn't get a job
cleaning out septic tanks which is
actually honorable business
and all of a sudden you now own yourself
a time share oh and then you die
with some money in your estate in trust
and your kids get sued by your timeshare
company
what a blessed group of people they are
unbelievable
stay away from this industry folks it's
nasty bad
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
jesus
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you